is that Captain Adam Captain Adam yes
Captain Adam holy the one and only
the entire island has only 400 residents
so I guess I shouldn't be surprised when
the guy I hitched a ride with to get to
the island also runs the local oyster
Farm
a man of many things apparently welcome
you guys want to check out some oysters
yes please
we need a hundred yeah the dinner yeah
we got them right here you want to help
me pick them up let's do it all right
you guys start what size are you looking
for so we're looking for a two and three
quarter three inch oyster so you've got
an oyster that touches on the bottom and
touches here that's a two and three
quarter oyster and you do that because
you want them to grow to their full
maturity yeah so when we Harvest for you
guys we just make sure they're all
perfect no pressure no pressure
it's just your debut dinner no big deal
[Music]
the oysters are sold all over the
country some of the best restaurants in
the world you know French Laundry and
all through New York and Boston and
California because North Haven has
beautiful soils the oceans clean and
that comes out in the taste and for
oyster aficionados
um it's a damn fine waste
foreign
[Music]
so I call Abel my oldest son we went
Lobster and an oystering together for
five years it really is a family out
here all of you on the island yeah
[Music]
in a community this small everyone
relies on each other and I can see that
Turner Farm plays a huge part in
supporting the whole island so everyone
here is personally invested in its
success
yeah
what do you think we have right now that
is definitely over 100. great okay yeah
10 103. good karma that's cool yeah done
all right you want to taste this I sure
do
right there's one of the most
beautifully salty oysters I've ever had
thank you so much
ever there's been so much hype around
these North Haven oysters I didn't know
what to expect but I love this sweet
salty creaminess and it's amazing and
honestly better than I could have ever
imagined
but I've also spotted something at
Adam's oyster farm that I want to share
with him
taste this that are really tender that
you can see a little heart what I'll try
that I'll try that thank you
oh my God that's good fantastic they're
like little tiny gherkins
oh and I like that correct sound so
satisfying think about if you dehydrated
this whole thing and deep fried the
whole thing and how the whole thing
would just pop up you had me at deep
fried Carolyn has a plan for oysters and
this great hot sauce but I'm kind of
inspired by this seaweed project I'm
going to call it a project for now
because I still have to figure out what
what I'm gonna do exactly
I want to do something unique surprising
something that will really add to what
Carolyn is already doing at Turner Farm
no clue what it's going to be yet but
I'll figure it out
[Music]
thank you